ils ont fait une maison avec des brindilles et le
jeu du loup il l'abat ouais ce qui
se passe au milieu continue à vouloir faire
ce petit cochon est allé au marché mais
c'est pour les orteils je ne savais pas que
vous vouliez des enfants vous devriez le faire
ouais vous feriez de si bons parents j'ai
vraiment adoré votre film est cette scène
avec les chiens autour des ordures comment avez-
vous mis en scène que j'ai dit hé tirez sur ces
chiens magnifiques vous voulez venir manger un
morceau avec nous avec un couple de 25
ans nous  nous n'avons que 25 ans, je veux dire que nous ne l'étions pas, mais
vous savez que ce sera amusant, nous avons rencontré ce
couple intéressant
quelle est la place pour le sous-mixage et je ne peux pas
m'engager là-bas et tout comme leur
appartement est plein de tout ce que nous avons jeté une fois
mais ça  ça a l'air si bon la façon dont
ils l'ont autour d'eux
vous dynamise c'est contagieux tu te moques de moi
regarde ça je t'aime
j'ai appris en cours de route tu peux
saboter plus en te permettant d'être
surpris par ce que tu rencontres quel
genre de processus nous  je suis inquiet pour vous les
gars  c'est avec le chapeau qu'est-ce que tu es un
vieil homme avec une tête pour la première fois
de ma vie j'ai arrêté de me considérer
comme un enfant imitant un adulte tu ressens
ça aussi
charge ta manche est en feu ça
va fils tu as de l'arthrite  dans ton genou
arthrite arthrite oui d'habitude je ne le
dis qu'une fois
avoir des enfants, je ne veux pas que ce
soit à chaque fois que vous
écoutez Gen vous voulez avoir un bébé, pas à chaque
fois